good morning John it's Wednesday March
3rd and I have good news and I have bad
news the bad news is that Viacom has
decided to not show The Daily Show in
The Colbert Report on Hulu anymore and
so I just have this to say Myakka and
the good news is that we have finished
the preliminary schedule for VidCon so
now you can actually see what's going to
be going on and since I've been doing it
myself it's hard to like get distance
from it but every once in a while I'm
just like holy crap all this stuff is
actually going to happen and those are
the moments I realized how it's going to
be worth all the trouble and how
extremely excited I am about this
happening John in reference to your last
video I have to say you know I really
don't like to agree with you on stuff so
I'm gonna start out by disagreeing with
you
I watched the marriage Ref and I didn't
think that it was that bad it might just
be that I have this gigantic and kind of
creepy inappropriate man crush on Jack
Donaghy / Alec Baldwin but I thought it
was entertaining and I don't think
anybody was taking it seriously
compared to The Bachelor this is
freaking fantastic I mean at least
they're not trying to get the married
that they're already married before they
get to the reality show that that's fine
with me
but of course this doesn't mean that
Jeff Zucker is right about anything that
he says about youtube I think he's
probably right about plenty of the
things that he thinks about TV because
it's his job to think about TV and
having Jeff Zucker talk about YouTube
it's kind of like having Tiger Woods
host the marriage Ref you know he's
astoundingly unqualified and absolutely
clueless because guess what YouTube
isn't a new way of experiencing old
things and that's what Jeff Zucker
thinks he thinks that YouTube is just a
new version of America's Funniest Home
Videos without Bob Saget which is
probably in terms of how America's
Funniest Home Video is gonna go you know
better but all you really have to do is
ask Jeff Zucker to go check out the top
20 most subscribed channels on YouTube
and see that 19 of those channels are
creating kinds of content that doesn't
have a name because they didn't exist
five years ago most of it is what I
started to call social video even when
it's Miley Cyrus vlogging it's still a
personal interaction it's not the same
kind of entertainment that these people
are used to it's not reality television
it's what we call reality even if it's
Shane Dawson playing a character it
still Shane Dawson doing something that
you if you were as talented as Shane
Dawson could do it's just him he doesn't
have editors or
writers are a marketing budget it's just
shame it's a completely different way of
communicating and being entertained it's
a completely new type of video it's
about authenticity and connecting on a
different level it's about being
entertained in a far more deep and
interesting way and all this adds up to
why I'm interested in having VidCon
exists I honestly believe that there is
something interesting and important
going on here on YouTube what I feel
like VidCon is about is getting together
the people that understand what's going
on not Jeff Zucker you know he's not
invited well he is invited he could come
if he wants but I want the people who do
understand to get together so we can
talk about it we can learn about it we
can get ready for what's coming next and
we can plan what that's gonna be
and most of all I want to celebrate it
because I really think it's worth
celebrating so that's why we're mixing
together more serious talks like say
Frank talking about the importance and
legitimacy of his relationship with the
virtual and just plain entertaining and
fun stuff like rhettandlink writing a
song on stage with your input and
mystery guitar man making a stop-motion
music video would sounds that you make
everyone from the sxephil to the
community channel there will be dozens
of meetups and classroom sessions during
the breakouts and YouTube the folks from
the actual company of YouTube will be
there as well to take suggestions from
us and to talk about what YouTube is and
what they're trying to do and how they
feel about what we're doing with this
platform that they've given us dance
parties and concerts and karaoke and
sword swallowing juggling acts which for
real
that's what there's gonna be a sword
swallower they're the 9th and the 10th
they're gonna be absolutely packed with
stuff and then the 11th we're leaving
open for people to design and do their
own things with there's obviously way
too much to talk about here with the
schedules for the 9th and the 10th are
up at VidCon 2010 there's a link in the
doobly-doo and you can go now and see it
all
John I will see you tomorrow